Time is a valuable resource.
Everyone gets the same amount of time,...
...but we cannot get any more time regardless of how much we would be willing to pay for it.
Although money is also a valuable resource,...
...it is renewable and limitless.
When I'm out of money, I can earn some,...
...or I can ask to borrow some.
However, money also provides privileges.
I can pay somebody to do my tasks, which gives me free time.
In spite of these differences, there are also many parallels between time and money.
You can save and spend both.
Both are in demand and there is never enough of either of them.
Whichever is more valued depends on the individual and their personal circumstances.
The question is really, "How do I want to spend the time that I have?"
"Do I want to sacrifice my valuable time earning or saving more money...
...or do I want to spend it with other pursuits?"
For most people, though, it will mean not choosing either one or the other,...
...but an ongoing battle to find a balance between the two.